in the UK and I think possibly other
parts of Europe TVs have caught our
analog then there was no digital TV for
another 20 odd years but what but the
the analog signal effectively only used
about half of the transmit time for
about half of the time it was in flyback
horizontally or vertically
and this time was allowed the fairly
antiquated analog circuits to keep up
and this meant that the work there were
lines that were not used for
transmitting a picture and in the UK in
Europe so fairly simple digital
information was overlaid on those lines
and in the system that became known as C
facts or teletext I think there were
there were different trade names
depending on which broadcaster you F
referring to these used a particularly
efficient mode of display where were the
kilobyte of RAM you could basically fill
the TV screen with multi-coloured text
and fairly blocky graphics and the BBC
was keen that the BBC micro supported
that display standard so this was added
to the basic proton architecture he was
quite tricky to add because the proton
used display modes that were divided
down from 16 megahertz bit rates telly
text display required hit six megahertz
okay and it's fairly easier to spot the
six megahertz isn't easily arrived at by
dividing 16 megahertz so I came up with
her what I think was a really rather a
neat fudge it was done digitally it
didn't use a phase lock loop or anything
that complicated it basically used edges
in the 16 megahertz signal that were
reasonably close and then rather crude
RC delays to just shift them a little
bit in the right direction to produce
something that was fairly close to a
real 6 megahertz signal
you